mecheri vous savez qu'aujourd'hui 11
novembre elle avait raison légalement
kelly puisque c'est la journée
internationale des célibataires alors
c'est une fête qui a été créée dans les
années 90 par un petit groupe
d'étudiants chinois qui voyaient dans
cette date un signe puisque c'est le 11
1 donc 1 1 1 1
le chiffre premier représente
l'individualité en chine et je me suis
dit que c'était l'occasion pour qu'on en
apprennent un peu plus sur vous alors
qui est célibataire autour de la table
moi je m'en 1,2 à les deux mais de là à
wayne et de la wii c'est tout mais vous
n'avez connu
et vous alors à n'être que de si la
patate année mais un souper alors
demandé justement ce questionnaire sont
intéressants quand vous êtes vous
monsieur
alors monsieur patate que vous êtes
célibataire
non je crois qu'il sort avec le cheptel
et frites elles le taux maximum et vous
rester célibataire bah ça fait trois ans
ces trois en ce moment-même 3 3 ans et
plus et de gâchis et vous et vous mais à
partir de combien de temps on n'est plus
célibataire faut rester comme lundi soir
à partir de combien partir de combien de
jours en somme on caste célibat si on
sort et quelqu'un un jour parce qu'on
n'est plus célibataire
ah oui bah oui mais je ne parle pas de
sexe on parle d'amour c'est papa
d'accord valable attendait si on parle
d'amour alors que les pandas qui sont là
par vous savez pourquoi on ne citera pas
qu'est ce qui vous manque le plus dans
votre vie de célibataire vous quand vous
avez le sentiment amoureux honnêtement
c'est vraiment bon et moi la tendresse
la tendresse
c'est beau et vous benhaim quand vous
êtes célibataire vous avez jamais été
célibataire je suis resté de plus de 11
ans avec le papa de mon fils après j'ai
été pendant quatre ans célibataire et
puis après ça fait sept ans j'ai 4 ans
célibataire ah ouais gros lolos mais je
viens même si son aventure
non beinheim minutes où on n'est pas là
j'ai déjà cher total les lie mafia chez
les deux mythes aulas c'est bon je
connais tous les deux donc arrêté 10 ans
descendait à détailler tout on est
pareil avec bâle s'est dévoué karim
haggui vous n'êtes jamais rester
célibataire n'ont que castaldi en fait
puisqu'il fait federal x commun
[Applaudissements]
c'est à toi mais comme un signe à la map
est pas florès écrit mais c'est ça non
deux semaines je devrais ces cellules à
terme à dix quand même ces fous de ça à
deux semaines et vous vous la guerre
vous à ses parents quand on est
célibataire ce qui est bien c'est qu'on
est pas obligé de faire attention on
peut se relâcher on peut mettre des
vieilles pantoufles une digue rome de
chalain alors qu'on voit rien les
voitures lutins à l'époque marcotte ne
sont pas célibataires avec des pontons
vous dis moi aussi c'est vrai
franchement c'est vrai oui par mois moi
j'étais célibataire après mon divorce
quelques mois je vais divorcer
oui je vis pas comme ça c'était il ya
six ans attendent sinon bah moi pas des
moutons se connaissaient déjà
oui et c'est vrai que j'aurais pu
intervenir dans 10 nov c'est même pour
ça qu'elle est passée par avion
[Applaudissements]
je m'attend j'ai peur qu'ils fassent ils
adorent ça va je suis maintenant on va
vous dévoiler dans un instant qui est le
chroniqueur masqué et vous non je pars
c'est très longtemps célibataire un an
je crois en tout d'accord alors non mais
c'est vachement bien alors voilà je vous
dis dîna deux célibataires dans
l'émission c'est vous donc cette fête et
leur amour en août c'est jean-michel et
qui fait de rémy allait si bien entendu
voilà reste le portrait robot de ski non
non je crois pas non non c'est moi ou il
en fût